- Hey guys, my name's Hal.
- I'm Delisa.
- I'm Vaughn.
- And we just did something
pretty crazy the other night,
and we want to tell you all about it,
so story time!
- Can we get some wine?
- Yeah, I think it's
time to pour some wine.
- Let's get some wine.
(upbeat music)
- What do you think the
title of the story should be?
- How about, "One Night in
Trump's Childhood Home"?
- I like it, clear, concise.
"One Night in Trump's Childhood Home."
Cheers!
- Cheers.
(upbeat orchestral music)
- You're from Queens.
- I am, I'm from Queens.
- And I just saw your
childhood home is for sale.
- Oh wow, I want to see that.
- [Donald Trump] That's it!
- [Jimmy Fallon] That's your house?
- [Donald Trump] That's where I was born.
- How in the world did
you find out about this?
- Okay, so the story goes:
On Buzzfeed.com, an article
popped up and it was all about
how Trump's childhood
home is now an Airbnb.
I saw the article, and I immediately said,
"I absolutely want to
make a video about this."
- I think there might be
something wrong with me
that made you think
that I would enjoy this.
- Well I thought that we all could
share this experience together
and it would bring us closer.
- I didn't have very many expectations.
What do you think it's gonna smell like?
- Old white man.
- Yup. And a hint of Drakkar Noir.
(Delisa laughs)
But when I got there, I was like,
"Damn, this is nice."
You know this honestly kind of reminds me
of Privet Drive from Harry Potter.
- Okay, yeah!
(Vaughn laughs)
- Trump's childhood home.
- [Vaughn] Oh, my god.
I would say it was a very nice house,
especially for the era
in which it was built.
I would say that this
was a very nice house.
- [Hal] It definitely felt very Madmen.
All of the decor in the
house is Trump-themed,
which was really kind of freaky to me.
There's like cardboard cutouts of Trump,
and photos of Trump, and quotes
by Trump all over the house.
Welcome!
- Everywhere I look, there's
something with his face on it.
Everywhere!
- Wow! This is wild.
- My favorite room was the large room
that had so much space for activities.
I was doing leaps, jetes.
This is bigger than my apartment,
and it's only one bedroom.
Wow!
- At the back of the house was the study.
I could really see like,
young Donald crapping in
his diaper back there.
"Listen, this crap is huge."
- "Listen, the crap in my diaper is huge."
- Huge.
- I sound like Jerry Seinfeld,
(Vaughn laughs)
not Donald Trump.
There's also an entire shelf,
and all that's in the shelf is
like a shrine to Donald Trump,
and the Trump board game.
- This is weird.
It says, "This bedroom is likely
"the childhood bedroom
President Donald J. Trump,
"who lived in this home from '46 to '50."
I'm confused as to why it says
this was likely the bedroom of child...
Like, do they not know?
- It's a pretty expensive
Airbnb, so yeah I agree.
Like, if you're gonna stay
here, you'd wanna definitely
for sure want to know.
- I would want to
for sure know which room was the Donald's.
- [Hal] I thought the weirdest
room was the master bedroom
with that whack as hell sign
that was hanging above the bed.
- I think I'm in the master bedroom.
Here it looks like there's
something that says,
"In this bedroom,
President Donald J. Trump
"was likely conceived by his
parents, Fred and Mary Trump.
"The world has never been the same."
Can't argue with that one.
- I just don't understand
why it needed to be said.
I think we all could have
inferred, or gathered.
The fact that there was a gold plaque,
that was a little much.
- [Hal] This is the
room where it happened.
And by it, I mean, Donald Trump's
- [Both] Conception.
- I never wanted to think
about that conception,
but here I am in the damn room.
- [Hal] There were, "The
Art of the Deal" copies
in every single room of that house.
- [Vaughn] Literally, this
is in absolutely every room.
Like they were not kidding
when they said that.
- [Hal] Every bathroom was
bright Pepto Bismol pink.
- And then that one large ass tub.
- [Hal] You did not like that tub.
- Best believe I am not
getting my ass in that tub.
- So when it was time to go to bed,
how were we all feeling?
(quirky music)
- Y'all, I feel weird.
I might need to go check into
like a La Quinta Inn or something.
- This is getting creepy.
Regardless of who lived there before,
it was just an old home.
And it was very quiet,
and it was just creaky and eerie.
I was uncomfortable.
- So I'm making Hal
come downstairs with me
to get the WiFi password because
I'm too scared to do it by myself.
- Okay guys, I'm going to bed.
I'm gonna do it.
I am gonna sleep in the room
where Donald Trump was conceived.
God, okay.
Goodnight.
- So, I just went to
the restroom by myself.
I'm like low-key nervous to just like
walk back to the bedroom.
Yeah, it's 3 o'clock in the morning,
and I'm absolutely terrified.
Pro-tip: Always go to the
restroom before you go to bed.
(quirky music)
- Delisa, how are you feeling?
Hard to sleep, not gonna lie.
- Bye Trump house.
Bye Trump's parent's room.
Bye Trump's room.
- Okay, the car is coming in four minutes.
Any final thoughts?
- [Vaughn] Politics aside,
I think that being there
in this home with this public
figure you know so well,
and you knew that this was his beginning.
That was his inception, and his conception
(all laugh)
- [Delisa] All the -ceptions.
- [Vaughn] All the -ceptions
happened in that damn house.
- [Delisa] I'm glad I went
through that with y'all.
I don't think it would have been as fun
if it wasn't for y'all.
- That is definitely an
experience I will never forget,
and an experience I never
want to have again. (laughs)
(Delisa laughs)
- Amen to that.
I am finishing this wine.
- Finish it.
(upbeat orchestral music)